So let's sort of focus
on privacy threats and
the context of tracking information or
online information.
Somebody tracks your
activities that you do online.
Okay, so tracking, essentially,
it's collection of information about
the activities that you do online.
So, a threat is collection
of such information,
the act of tracking what you do.
If they do it with your
consent that's one thing.
But doing it without your consent,
obviously, that many of us,
we'll view as invasion of our privacy.
Okay, so one threat is without consent,
doing this without consent.
If they have collected this
information how can they use?
How did I agree to this specific
use that they have in mind?
If I had not agreed to it, or
this was not sort of revealed to me,
well, that's a threat to my privacy.
How long can they keep some information
that I agreed they can collect about me?
We're talking tracking information.
You went through a certain website,
you searched for results.
How long do they keep this information?
Who do they share this information with?
Maybe this information has some value
associated because it describes me,
what I do,
what my preferences may be and
things like that, so they can
actually sell it to somebody else.
And if they're selling to somebody else,
did I agree to it?
Are these parties that
I had authorized or
I had given consent that
sharing is okay with me?
Or do they do it without my knowledge?
If they do it without my knowledge,
of course,
that's another privacy threat, because
my information then gets to somebody
else that I had no idea that they
would be able to gain access to it.
So, I may actually specify
what they can collect, and
who they can share it with and
how long they can retain.
So that's what the constitutes
we're going to see and
examples that are privacy
policy that we agree to.
But what if the policy changes actually,
so information collected by me, actually
they change it to a more lax policy,
then they don't ask me to agree to it.
Then they will be able to do things that
they were not able to do before, and
they're not able to do those
things before because they hadn't
agreed to it, to them.
So, now by changing the policy they
could basically can get around that
requirement that I give explicit
consent and that's a threat if
all privacy policies can be changed
to anytime without informing me and
getting my consent,
then that's a threat to my privacy.
And finally,
sort of information security,
this is what we're talking about,
they collect all this information.
What if they have a breach?
The bad guy walks away
with all this information.
They didn't explicitly share it with
the bad guy, they were trying to sort of
respect my privacy and only share it
with whoever I had agreed to, but
a bad guys, they don't care
about consent and agreement.
The reason they were able to reach and
gain access to this information that's
private is may be my information
security was not what it should be.
We hadn't have good
identity access management,
didn't have good monitoring and
place and various other threats.
So, if they are going to collect this
information and in good faith going to
try to use it the way you agree
that they be able to use it.
Well, we still have to
protect it from the bad guys.
And if they don't,
that is a privacy threat.